your brain doesn't know the difference
between an event that you have closed
your eyes and imagined and an event that
you've actually done and so here's
what's really cool what I just told you
is manifesting seriously manifesting
done correctly is when you use your
procedural memory as a tool to train
your brain your nervous system your
spirit to help you feel motivated and to
help you do the work that actually
changes your life how cool is that I
want to be very clear about something
you know manifesting gets a bad rap
because of the Law of Attraction but
manifesting is not woo-woo at all it's
not a Cheesy topic manifesting is not
just think about something that you want
and suddenly it'll magically appear no
no no no
manifesting is when you use your
procedural memory and you visualize the
step-by-step actions that you need to
take in order to make your big goal or
the thing that you want or the new habit
to become a reality you see manifesting
isn't the end everybody manifesting is
the bridge it's the series of actions
that you're gonna take in order to have
this new habit hey it's Evan Carmichael
and I make these videos because in my
first business I quit on my business
partner I was making 300 bucks a month
and I didn't have the motivation to keep
going and the thing that got me through
was studying the stories of
entrepreneurs who've had massive success
and I hope that in sharing these stories
with you you find a motivation to keep
going and if I'm being honest I still
need the source for myself today too so
today let's learn from some of the best
and pick up some powerful manifestation
techniques enjoy
technique number two practice creative
visualization with Gabby Bernstein
that's the first step is to really
accept that you do have the power to
create the world that you want to see
and you can totally tweet that because
it's something we've got to share we got
to put out we've got to know it and that
first step of knowing it is really
probably the most crucial step in the
creative visualization process the next
step is to really just begin to suspend
disbelief begin to look at the things
that you want to create and take all
that disbelief and reorganize it
reprogram it change your perception
around it because when we're in that
story of disbelief that's what we're
creating so take a minute to really look
at all the disbelief and find a way to
reframe it but reframe it in a way that
you believe it so if you've got
disbelief that you could never lose that
weight start to reframe it with a belief
system that's that's truthful to you
that's natural to you something along
the lines of I believe that I can get to
the gym every day and that's my first
step I believe that I have the power to
eat more healthfully so leaning into a
belief system them that is real for you
that you can actually hold on to that
you can actually believe in because if
you start to use affirmations and
reframes that you don't believe in they
won't work that's just the bottom line
they won't work so Reach For Thoughts
that you believe in
and then the next step is to sit in a
daily experience of visualization
visualize yourself going to that gym
visualize yourself in that healthy body
visualize yourself eating that healthy
meal and chewing it slowly or visualize
yourself on that date with that partner
that you long for or visualize yourself
working with the people that you love to
work with that support you so much and
then the next and final most important
step is to allow that visualization to
become a feeling let that visualization
take over you emotionally so you can
genuinely feel a connection to what
you're seeing so I allow my mind to
wander and I see myself in what it is
that I desire and then I let the feeling
take over the feeling of being taken
care of the feeling of being supported
the feeling of working and co-creating
with people that I love and and that's
what I'm currently visualizing and so
being in that feeling is what truly
manifests this into form what's most
awesome also is that you start to feel
what you want to create even before it
comes into form so it's as if it's
already happened and that's actually the
key Point here which is that you being
in the energy of what it is that you
want to create actually makes it so that
it is there even if you can't see it and
you got to believe it before you see it
as my teacher Dr Wayne Dyer always said
so take these steps suspend disbelief
choose to reframe those stories and see
them in a really high Vibe affirmation
bring that thought and that Vision into
the creative visualization process where
you sit and Stillness in your meditation
and allow your mind to wander and see
visions of what you really want to call
in and then be in the feeling of what it
is that you desire technique number
three control your thoughts with Joe
dispenza I don't ever think that there's
a time where you're isn't influencing
your body and a time where your body
isn't influencing your mind
but from a very simplistic standpoint
when you have a thought every time you
have a thought you make a chemical
and when you fire that thought the brain
produces a chemical it signals the body
for you to begin to feel exactly the way
you were just thinking
so if you have a joyful thought you make
chemicals that make you feel Joy if you
have a self-depreciating thought it your
body switches on a different set of
circuits than the brain and produces
different chemicals and you feel
unworthy
the problem is is the moment we start
feeling unworthy the moment we start
feeling unhappy the moment we start
feeling angry the brain checks in with
the body and it causes the body causes
the mind to think the same thoughts
equal to how it's feeling so then the
person starts thinking more thoughts
equal to that feeling firing and wiring
certain networks in the brain and
setting the same to the body
so thoughts are the language of the
brain and feelings of the language of
our body and how we think and how we
feel creates our state of being so it
makes sense then
that some people get caught in these
Loops of thinking and feeling and
feeling and thinking
for years on end
and the redundancy of that cycle the
thought and the feeling
an image or a memory and an emotion a
stimulus in response is what conditions
the body emotionally
like any conditioning process
to live in the past now the body is the
objective mind
it doesn't know the difference between
the real life experience that's creating
that emotion and the emotion that the
person is fabricating by thought alone
so most emotions are chemical records of
the past
so the person by living by the same
emotional state
their body leaving us in the same past
experience
24 hours a day seven days a week and 365
days a year to the body the body's
literally emotionally conditioned into
the past
Well
turns out that
certain thoughts that we think that
produce certain chemicals either cause
the body to flourish
and to grow and certain thoughts cause
it to weaken and the response then
causes the body to move out of balance
now here's an example in the short story
we all know that when we are threatened
or there's some danger in our outer
world where we feel like we lost control
of something and we can't predict what's
going to happen next or we have the
constant perception that things in our
life are going to get worse we turn on a
very primitive system an alarm system an
emergency system that says that there's
a threat and a danger
and what happens is the body mobilizes
enormous amounts of energy and chemicals
to prepare us for that danger or our
threat well that's sympathetic response
and for the short term
all organisms in nature can tolerate
short-term stress
the problem is is that when there's that
arousal of chemicals that's created the
person becomes
conditioned or needs the rush of that
adrenaline the rush of that chemical to
feel something
so if you start responding to the people
in your life or the circumstances in
your life and the conditions in your
life and your response is producing that
emergency system
then over time when your pupils dilate
and your salivary juices shut down and
blood is sent to your extremities and
your heart rate increases your
respiratory rate increases your body's
prepared for that danger but what if
you're sitting in traffic
what if you're sitting next to an in-law
what if you're sitting next to a
co-worker in a cubicle or watching the
news
so what happens is is that our response
to the environment
the arousal causes us to pay more
attention to our problems
and this is where it gets dangerous
because we can think about our problems
and we can turn on that same stress
response just by thought alone now
stress is when your brain and body are
knocked out of homeostasis is when
you're knocked out of balance you keep
knocking the body out of balance
that imbalance becomes the new balance
and now the person's headed for disease
because no one can live in emergency
mode in that state where you're putting
all your attention on your outer world
there's no energy for growth and repair
in your inner World Okay so
it's a scientific fact that the hormones
of stress push the genetic buttons
buttons long-term and create disease
well if you can turn on the stress
response just by thought alone thinking
about your problems
that means that your thoughts can
literally make you sick
so the question is if your thoughts
could make you sick
is it possible that your thoughts can
make you well and we have spent over 10
years of studying this mind-body
connection and the mind and the body are
always talking to each other also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video I've designed
a special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there technique number four rewire your
brain with John Ashraf we may be wired
with limiting beliefs we may be wired
with low self-esteem we may be wired to
fear fear failure or fear disappointing
ourselves again or fear getting up and
speaking because when we were a kid we
got up and kids made fun of us that we
gave the wrong answer
we can now rewire our brain to have more
confidence more certainty more
empowering beliefs to let go of stupid
fears that hold us back because of
something we did in childhood or because
something that our parents said or a
friend said or a brother or sister said
to embarrass us or make us feel ashamed
of ourselves
so the greatest Discovery science of
neuroplasticity
shows that the neurons the brain cells
that fire together wire together and the
neurons that we fire deliberately that
wire together and we do that over days
and months and weeks we can literally
rewire our brain to earn more money
rewire our brain to release the
self-image of being overweight rewire
our brain to be more confident more
certain uh and and that is an Incredible
Gift that we have we don't have to
settle for what is we don't have to
settle for our our present circumstances
we don't have to settle for a life of
stress and anxiety and uncertainty
but we can settle for
is our unlimited potential well we can
settle for is the ability for us to
reinvent ourselves to reinvest in
ourselves to deliberately and
consciously
evolve ourself
by thinking the thoughts that we want to
think by feeling the emotions we want to
feel by behaving in ways that match the
success that we want and if we do that
for a week for a month for two months
for three months we deliberately Break
Free of the old patterns
and create new ones and reinforce those
is it possible
that then our brain goes to work for us
and it deletes or distorts all the old
that holds us back and it starts to help
us create the most amazing life that we
want technique number five focus on what
you want with Rhonda Byrne I wanted to
say this and I talk about it in the
sacred and we have been so orientated
toward action
that we that was one of the beliefs
remember that I said that we have to do
something to get something because you
can't get anything for nothing
so you definitely don't have to take
action
that is a world belief it really is it's
a world belief
um
so
I just want you to know that your focus
of what you want is more more is
stronger and more powerful than any
action you could ever take if you stay
focused for one minute on something you
want honestly it's like 10 years of
action so understand the incredible
mental power that you have to bring
about what you want in the world every
single thing you do in life
is following a thought you can't do
anything without having the thought
first of all to do it and so thought
always precedes everything else and so
and so if
and so in a nutshell
thought is more powerful than any action
you can ever take
and that should help you in your life to
just remember that and technique number
six the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is be a creator with
sad Guru
you don't have to be on the go all the
time
if life demands people ask me how are
you active like this because generally
my schedule is anywhere between 18 to 20
hours a day seven days of the week 365
days non-stop for many years it's going
on
so people keep asking how do you keep
yourself like this how do you do this
see I am essentially lazy
it's just that
the situation in the world demands
action
left to myself I would close my eyes and
simply say it
I'm made like this if I close my eyes I
can sit like this till I fall dead
really I have really no need for Action
I'm not trying to keep myself busy
there's a lot to be done so you're doing
people ask me satguru what's your dream
what is your dream I said my dream is
the day I am unemployed that's a great
day because if I'm unemployed it simply
means everybody is doing fantastic
what more do you want dream fulfilled so
action is not something that you decide
you just decide your intent
action the world will decide how much of
what
I am you know at these economic forums
and says World economic forum
this guy in front of Business Schools in
Harvard Business School when Professor
comes oh you're that amazing tree
planter
I said no I am not a tree planter he
said no no you planted those Millions
cities yes I did but I'm not a tree
planter
us then what do you do I said uh I make
people flowers
not plant trees but I'm planting trees
because the goddamn trees are missing
where they should have been
where they should have been they are not
there it's like this two men were
working on the street
one man is digging pits behind him
another man is coming and closing and
closing and going
somebody else was driving by they saw
this ridiculous Activity one guy digs
the pit another guy closes the pit so
they stopped and said hey what are you
doing here why are you guys working like
this one guy digging another guy closing
they said no no uh the in-between guy
has gone and leave he's the tree planter
he's not there we're doing our work
so a lot of people are doing work legs
I'm doing my work
you have no work on this planet the
planet needs work if the world needs
work we will do it otherwise why should
I think this is my work
what's your mission so no Mission I'm
just fooling around a bit
because
you have no business
to have your own mission
life has its own mission in some way if
you can assist and serve that that's
about it what is it that you have your
own mission are you some kind of a
tyrant all missionaries are tyrants in
some way annoyingly yes those who think
they have a mission there is no Mission
what is needed you do especially when
you study in a business school and get
certain competence to manage things or
create things
you must create what is needed not
create some rubbish and push it on them
yes
yes or no
you must see how to make life better how
to solve situations which are
problematic to a whole lot of people you
must look for Solutions and solutions
for the existing situations and of
course there are experts who go on
creating new problems
so you will never be short of problems
believe me
you just have to create Solutions not go
on a mission mode
you have no idea what you're capable of
you have no idea you have no idea the
person you could be the thing you could
accomplish the things you can do the
people you can serve you have no idea
that's why I don't like 10-year goals
10-year goals think about who you used
to be 10 years ago you know could that
person accurately with any with any
degree of certainty predict where you
could be right now now like if you're
growing and you're learning you're
improving and you're expanding
you're invested in yourself there's no
way that you know where you're going to
be in one year let alone five years or
ten years you have no idea what you're
capable of and so it comes down to
questioning everything
the question what you can and can't do
you know we're told the story growing up
of what you should do and we're told
everything right you're told when to
show up and where to go and what to wear
and what to eat and what at what age you
should get married and what kind of
career you should go into right we're
told we should do all these things
you're told you're like who you know
nobody ever thought to ask us what we
want for our lives and you may not even
know and that's okay like you may know
where you want to go next but you may
not ultimately know the Final
Destination it's awesome
you know I think if you know the Final
Destination you're thinking small apart
from having a mission you know the
mission the purpose why do you do what
you do I want to solve the world's
biggest problem people don't believe in
themselves enough that's what I'm
chasing down every day
do I know where I'm going to be in a
year nope am I still making videos
probably but who knows like question
everything I wanna I want people to
believe in themselves more what's the
best way to do that right now it's
through YouTube
but I think a lot of times people have
too certain of a plan and then they end
up
playing small because there's nothing
wrong with having goals and plans but
sometimes you need to jump off that if
you have a 10-year goal quite often you
need to jump off that goal two years in
because something better has come along
that actually better serves who you are
right now because the goal you set was
for who you used to be
you know if you felt that and so I'm
here at a genius Network and this group
of super successful entrepreneurs that
meets once a month in masterminds and
talk about their business and pay a lot
of money to be a part of something like
this and every time I'm around people
who are who are having a high degree of
success
I always try to have them pick me apart
so when we when we do there's an
exercise called hot seats where you go
around the table and you basically share
what your biggest
what you think your biggest problem is
and whenever it gets to my turn I just
want people to ask me questions
because
your biggest problem is you don't know
what your biggest problem is
right your biggest problem is you don't
know what your biggest problem is if you
know what your biggest problem was you
can go and solve it
for for entrepreneurs for ambitious
people for you've got goals it's like
you don't know what the real problem is
the problem you think you have is a
problem you know the problem you think
you have yes very much is a problem but
there's a deeper problem underneath it
that you're missing
that I'm missing so this is where
question everything becomes important my
default has become instead of pretending
like I know everything and I know all my
problems that I don't know anything and
ask me questions and in the process of
asking me questions and learning about
me maybe you come up with some insight
that I've never seen before
everybody has their own way of
processing
um given advice you know so I'm around
people here everybody here has a seven
or eight figure or nine figure business
and people here have sold their
businesses
for nine figures crazy
awesome
and so they have their own way of
processing things and asking questions
and breaking somebody down
so instead of me coming in with
the question and having them trying to
fit into my box I'd rather fit into
theirs because in trying to understand
how they process things
it'll probably make me stretch and grow
and learn
and I'm probably going to get a better
result because they're going to see
something that I don't see
and so
in the process of questioning everything
when people can break you down and
you're open to it right because we're we
hold on to our identity like no that's
not going to work for me you know even
boom got a B I am allergic to bees
maybe I should question that I don't
feel like questioning that today though
do not want to get stung by a bee I once
got stung by a bee and uh only time in
my life I've been sung by bee and it I
was on the floor and my my back just
swelled up from the bee sting
um
anyway maybe question everything except
bee stings how about that uh there's
been times when people have given me
advice and it made sense and it really
fit and sometimes when it didn't
and and even if it doesn't make sense
what I'll default in my head the same is
this is either nothing like the person
didn't read me correctly or it's the
whole thing
think about if you're really opposed to
somebody's advice or feedback for you if
somebody gives you great advice like oh
wow that's really cool I should go and
do that cool they they met you where you
were at and you understand it
but there'll be other times when it it
doesn't feel right
and it could be that it just wasn't a
fit and they're giving you the wrong
advice or
you're so blind and this is what gets me
excited is maybe I'm so blind maybe I
believe my story so much that the thing
that you're talking about is actually
the whole thing like it's all I should
care about because figuring out how to
solve that because I'm so tied to my own
story that I'm not questioning enough
and coming back to the B Spot hopefully
it's gone I'm not questioning enough
and figuring that out becomes the the
whole unlock so a quick story on this I
did a life coaching session with
garyvee's lead coach Beth hendel and at
first I was shocked I didn't know I
didn't know garyvee had a life coach so
I was very excited to talk to her and
just like I've been explaining this
video I went through her process like
like how do you ask questions what do
you want to know about me I don't want
it to be if this is a coaching session
just treat me as a shoot me as a client
treat me as somebody who's going to
coach what do you need to know from my
story and how I act and I'm gonna I'm
gonna be as open as honest as possible
and what it led to was
a lot of the stuff she was saying
um was great but my single biggest
insight and takeaway was this and I'm
practicing this every single day now
the one takeaway that has honestly
changed my life
historically I've been the person who
believes in the plan
so what's my plan to get to the next
step like I want to go here what's my
plan what's my plan what's my plan so I
have the belief in the plan and I wake
up every day and I just do the plan
because I believe in the plan
I have some days where I don't believe
in a plan anymore like will this plan
help get me anywhere is this plan still
working like it's not working anymore
and that leads to some anxiety for me
because I believe in the plan and when
the plan doesn't work what happens
and so what I'll end up doing is making
a new plan
so I have a plan I believe in a plan
until I don't believe in it anymore
causes anxiety come up with a new plan
the following so when creating a new
plan then I have certainty in the plan
again and I'm fine and I'm rock and
rolling but there are some days
there are some days when I can't come up
with a new plan the plan I have I don't
believe in anymore and I'm racking my
brain to come up with a new plan and I
can't come up with a new plan
if I'm the kind of person who believes
in the plane and then I can't come up
with a new plan that's a really uh
stress-inducing anxiety-filled place to
be and it doesn't happen that often
but when it does and I can't come up
with a new plan especially in the moment
while what I would end up telling myself
is great things happen to me you know
what you know what happened great things
happen to you
and I would use it as a self-soothing
mechanism as a coping mechanism
because I didn't want to just stay
locked because locked in that stress and
and it would be downward spiral
like if I believe in the plan and the
plan is not working and I can't come
with a new plan then I don't know what
to do with my life and that would create
a downward spiral I've never gone
anywhere close to depression or suicide
but that would lead to some dark that
could lead to some dark places and so
the way that I come out of it is just
say great things will happen to me great
things happen to me they already they
always happen to me great things happen
to me and I'll figure this out and that
gives me the Comfort to
move forward into the uncertainty and
then something will come that I will
solve it and what she said was garyvee's
life coach was
what you say to yourself
when you need that
self-soothing of great things happen to
you
needs to be your default state
so instead of believing in the plan as
your default State and only going to
great things happen to you when you are
at the lowest of your low
flip it to the point where great things
happen to you is the default
because that's where you're actually
your best self and I really felt that I
don't know how to do it
but even in questioning how do I do it
I just have to believe the great things
happen to me so a big part of my routine
now is is I don't know how many times
I'll I'll say that to myself feel that
great things happen to me I'm going to
put it as my new cell phone background
it's a it's a constant reminder even
making this video is another
reinforcement of it when people ask me
what my goals are there's been these
exercises we've been doing in genius
Network here and uh I just I just keep
reminding myself I don't know I don't
have a 10 year goal great things happen
to me
it's a constant reminder and I
I would I used to live it before this
awareness
I don't know like how many times would I
feel really down and low in
anxiety-filled that I couldn't come with
a new plan
maybe half of one percent of the time
like really small amounts and now I'm
probably living in great things happen
to me maybe
five percent of the time ten percent of
the time which is a huge jump from half
of one percent but it's still not my
default mode yet I'm still believing a
planned guy that's my ongoing challenge
to myself that's how I'm questioning
it's the willingness to question what
you're doing because what you're doing
right now has gotten you to where you're
at and if you're if you're happy with
where you're at cool but if you want
more you want to create more you want to
serve more you want to bring more you
want to help more you want more
you want to change and you have to
change
and the change starts with not just
questioning everything out there
question everything in here
questioning what you believe to be true
question who you think you are
questioning for sure what you think
you're capable of
because when you can get to the root of
that amazing things can happen the
majority of our thoughts and feelings
are connected to our sexuality
to our victimization our guilt our
suffering or shame or unworthiness or
self-doubt or our importance our control
our fear our anger our frustration our
hatred our judgment those are those are
the first three hormonal centers in the
body and and those first three centers
have everything to do with survival and
those centers are energy consumers
orgasm digestion stress is a lot of
energy that that we're drawing from our
very vital life force yes our resource
of light and information and we're
turning it into chemistry and we're
literally robbing the body's energy
right so so then living like that for
the short term is okay because the body
can move back to homeostasis and then
restore itself but
when we're overdoing that consistently
then there's no energy for growth and
repair there's because you're living
constantly in survival so again you can
eat all the right food you can do all
the right things but if you're living in
anxiety and fear and you're viewing your
world from the worst case scenario that
could possibly happen because that's
what you do in survival there's no
energy for growth and repair there's no
energy for healing so the majority of
our thoughts are signaling certain
circuits in the brain that signal
another part of the brain the limbic
brain to make what's called a
neuropeptide neuropeptides are chemical
Messengers that signal hormonal centers
so now you're taking thought and you're
storing it as energy in these energy
centers and and if you're living in
survival why would you open your heart I
mean it's just not a time to open your
heart I mean if you're getting chased by
T-Rex it's not a time to meditate it's
not a time to learn it's not a time to
connect it's not a time to communicate
it's not a time to sit down and go
within it's not a time to be vulnerable
it's time to run fighter hide and so is
that why we're this way I've never asked
you this before is this some I don't I
don't think you believe this but I just
want to understand is this some sort of
genetic disposition that's been passed
down to us since we've been chased by
T-Rex I think so I think survival has
been very adaptive yeah like because if
you're being chased by T-Rex you don't
run up to T-Rex T-Rex and say oh cute
little dinosaur only pet you that's not
adaptive the fear is adaptive you run
from the unknown you run from challenges
right yes so if you're living in
survival there's better chances of
surviving if you run from the unknown
and by the way when you're living in
survival that the infinite Potentials in
the quantum field you'll select the
worst case scenario in your mind and
you'll begin to emotionally prepare
yourself for the worst case scenario
because you have better chances of
surviving there you go if you prepare
for the worst right so people spend
their whole life yes thinking about the
worst thing and emotionally embracing it
while you take a thought and emotion or
an image and an emotion you're your
branding or conditioning your body into
what anxiety into fear so then you keep
doing that over and over again over and
over again your the body becomes the
mind of fear and whether you think you
can control it or not you're gonna have
a panic attack and the panic attack is
the body saying you've conditioned me
this way try as you may with your
conscious mind and control it right you
programmed it subconsciously then you
start worrying about the next panic
attack and it's that very anticipation
it keeps the person on the hamster wheel
it robs them of all of this energy as
well they're absolutely so so they don't
believe
impossibility when they're living in
that state because in survival it's not
a time to create all the blood flows
going to the hindbrain and away from the
forebrain there's no there's there's no
physiology really for a person to begin
to create a new future so then so think
about it so then 70 of the time people
in the world are living anticipating the
next moment based on their past moment
and so they're laying reality down
Moment by moment with the next known the
next predictable moment and so the
hormones of stress endorse the senses
our senses become heightened when we're
under stress and we become materialists
we narrow our focus on the danger yes so
then you're focusing on matter you're
focusing on the material world and when
you do that you put all your attention
the arousal of the stress hormones puts
all your attention on your body if
you're being chased by T-Rex you better
be paying attention to your body I think
one of my first things in failure
is don't take it more personally than it
actually is and I'll give an example of
that when I was applying to 40 companies
that all rejected me before an interview
yeah all I was getting was an automated
response saying your application will
not go any further
I can't take that personally because
they didn't meet me in person they
didn't have a interaction with me they
just saw my name they saw I'd been a
monk for three years that resume is
useless I mean what's your transferable
skills like sitting in silence surprise
surprise no one wants to hire a monk and
so they rejected you but that's not
personal because they didn't meet me in
person but what if they had me right so
that's the first thing the first step is
don't take all fear failure I'll give an
example me and you we reach out to
countless guests to be on our podcast we
say no all the time we're saying all the
time but if I don't hear a no from the
guest directly that's not a no like
someone's team can say no someone's
assistant can say no someone's PR team
can say no but until they say no
personally it's not a no okay but when
they do say no then that's enough yeah
so then let's move how do you deal with
that type of failure yes so if I deal
with a failure where someone meets me in
person and gets to know no Jay you're
horrible you sucked like I don't want to
deal with a monk ever in my life yeah I
would never go on your show I'm never
listening to you never yeah then how do
you deal with that type of so I've had
you say this I've said it a couple of
times and I'm sure it's been repeated a
bunch of times around how I genuinely
believe failure has feedback feedback
and and so for me it's like failure has
the ability to actually tell you what
you need to improve now not to improve
to get their attention
improving to get the actions that you
want to take yeah the results you want
the results you want and don't make that
result about the person who said no
don't try use failure as a way to prove
someone else wrong because what happens
when we prove what others wrong when you
prove others wrong you end up trying to
get validation and approval for them and
now if they're not impressed when you're
right you lose again so you end up
losing twice and you spend all this time
and energy years maybe to prove
something wrong I've been there many
times and then you're like I felt good
for a moment yeah and then I feel empty
again totally and and so that's the
thing about failure in the second half
is you have to see failure as an
improvement if if I'm completely honest
everyone who rejected me in my life up
until now
has made me more hungry taught me so
much more about myself and made me up my
game yeah and I think if failure doesn't
make you up your game it's the same as
losing in a sport
right when you fail and you've lost
games and you've won games on the big
stages you didn't have the skills you
didn't have the teamwork you guys
weren't hungry enough you were
communicating enough there's something
you were missing yeah so you go review
the game film you check the stats you
see what could have done better and you
try to improve that for the next game
yeah and I think a lot of people can do
that in life but we're so afraid to like
go on the next game of life like I got
rejected once and it hurts so bad yeah
how do people learn to overcome that
pain of rejection yeah to keep going
yeah you know in sports luckily there's
a season which like you might have 30
basketball games after you lose the
first two you don't say uh I'm just
gonna give up the rest of the season
yeah you keep playing yes but in life a
lot of people stop playing yeah why yeah
I think that's great mental training too
I think Sports is great mental training
because you have to show up to the next
game even if you lost and you don't feel
bad exactly that you don't feel good
sorry and and one of the things before I
dive into that question one of the
things that you reminded me of was that
the Lost dance documentary so there's
that season that Michael Jordan everyone
is agreement in an agreement that he is
one of the best players to be playing
and they keep losing they need to make
the fight they didn't make the finals
they lost and then they realized they
need to get the team and they need to
find their I think they're bringing
Dennis Rodman and then they start
bringing in all these other players that
strengthen whereas if they would have
just said oh we got the best player in
the world we just keep doing this
I'm not sure what they would have got
there right but the coach Phil Jackson
and the team they had to adapt and so
you're saying why do we feel that pain
in rejection and how do we deal with
that
I think we feel that pain because we
look at a failure right we look at it as
a complete definition of us right we're
looking at as as uh there's that famous
statement of like you know failure is an
event not a person right and I don't
know who said it but it's one of those
statements that that really clicks like
failure is uh an event not a person
whereas we start thinking we are the
failure like we say I am
here's the hard truth about getting
great
it takes time and dedication it takes a
willingness to accept that you're not
yet good enough it takes the ability to
stare at the places that you know that
you're weak to really look at those
things and not let it affect your sense
of self-esteem and not let it affect
your sense of self-worth so that you can
still get the momentum going but you
have to understand that in the beginning
we're all terrible
and as Henry Cartier brasson said your
first 10 000 photographs are your worst
and so the thing that really makes great
art are the people that continue to push
and the people that continue to work and
face how inadequate they are and really
understand that at the end of the day
greatness is a craft greatness is a
process greatness is a habit greatness
is the little things that you do every
day over time going out every day
unafraid of whether or not this is one
of the ten thousand terrible things that
you're gonna do it's being unafraid to
make those mistakes is being unafraid
that you're not yet great
and as Marianne radmaker said courage
doesn't always Roar sometimes courage is
the quiet voice at the end of the day
saying I will try again tomorrow
and that's it if you want to be great
that's what you have to do you've got to
get up again tomorrow you've got to be
willing to face another day you've got
to be willing to accept that you've got
to get through the bad ideas before you
can get to the good you've got to
understand that you have to start as an
apprentice you have to start as a person
going and getting tea and you have to
accept that that's the job that you
should be playing that you should be
working for somebody else you should be
looking up to somebody else's seeing
what they can teach you because what you
know is that you're there to learn what
you know is that you're there to get
through the ten thousand bad photographs
that you need to get through to
ultimately achieve greatness and if you
make the catastrophic error that's so
many make
so try to tell the world that you're
extraordinary today to try to get the
world to follow you and look up to you
and think that you're something today
because the people that really win are
the ones that invest today the ones that
listen today the the ones that spend
every ounce of their energy amassing
Mastery getting better every day working
their asses off to improve their skill
set to relentlessly look at the things
that they're not doing well to
understand that they have to break
themselves down and get rid of all of
their ego before they can really find
greatness
those are the people that we remember
so if you want to be remembered if you
want to achieve real greatness
you just need to have the courage to
show up every day
and take another swing take another
photo try another task do something that
scares you and do those little things
over and over and over until you win I
used to struggle a lot with manifesting
just the idea of it I would watch videos
on it and I didn't understand what they
were saying I didn't I just didn't
understand it whether it's manifesting a
lot of attractions like what are they
saying I don't understand the words that
are coming out of your mouth and I would
rewind and watch again it's like I don't
get it I don't understand I don't I
don't understand and it seemed weird
silly not good enough for me to just sit
on the couch and think about money
coming into your wallet or whatever it
was that you're trying to manifest you
got to go do something that in law of
attraction you know action is at the end
of Attraction like you got to go off and
do the work if that's been you if you've
been kind of struggling with manifesting
or Law of Attraction you don't know how
it makes sense you rewind videos and it
feels too woo-woo for you let me uh let
me let me explain it from a different
perspective and and maybe it'll help at
least this is what's helped me the first
thing that I realized is
very scientific is from the reticular
activating systems as part of your brain
that decides what to pay attention to
and what to not pay attention to there
there are so many things that are
happening right now all around you that
you are not paying attention to most
things your brain filters out your the
job of the reticular activating system
you can go look it up Ras is to filter
out most things and only filter in the
things that you should care about so for
example
um you know what color are your socks
today what color is your underwear today
you know looking down this street and
you know I didn't know that there was a
pine tree here what are you paying
attention to as you look out the window
you're looking at the tree you're
looking at the the sign here you're
looking at the driveway you look at the
cuddle of the sky you're looking at the
house you look at the what material that
might be you're not looking at anything
again just too blurry you're still
looking at my face you're looking at my
car you're looking at the color of the
headrest you're looking at my outfit
like what are you paying attention to
most things you're ignoring
because there's no possible way to pay
attention to everything potentially the
dog just Anna hello good girl
right we're ignoring most things because
it wouldn't serve you it's just
impossible to be information overload if
you feel like you're overloaded already
just imagine if you took in absolutely
everything so your eyes are bringing it
in and your brain is filtering out most
of it so what does your brain actually
pay attention to well the reticular
activating system
will choose to say okay you've set an
intention right I want to pay attention
to X and now all of a sudden you're
going to see that more often I I'm I
just bought a house so in that process
we started paying attention a lot more
to houses so one of the things I noticed
was the for sale sign here where I may
have not noticed that as much in the
past but because thinking house boom now
I'm paying attention to the for sale
sign you ever notice when you buy a car
you start seeing that car everywhere
right or even thinking about buying a
car you're thinking about buying an X
you start seeing it on the street more
often
why that's your reticular activating
system basically saying I want to pay
attention to those things so that car
was still around right I mean I I got
this car we've got a Porsche and now I
see Porsches more often those Porsches
still existed they were they were
already there I just didn't notice them
before and now I notice them because I
have one right
um so whatever it is that you want
whatever it is that you're setting
attention towards it's not just sit on
your couch and meditate and imagine
money coming into your wallet or a new
car or new house or business growth or
you speaking on stage or whatever your
goals are right it's not just
sitting on it and visualizing it but
it's noticing it and the elements of it
in your environment that when you start
thinking about it right we are we we
consistently think about when you start
thinking about it you'll start seeing
opportunities around you that were
already there
you just filtered it out because you
didn't see how it connected
now your brain's starting to make those
connections does that make sense
reticular activating system you're
ignoring most things
but when you set intention on the thing
that matters to you you'll start seeing
it in your environment and opportunities
for that to happen a lot more often so
that's step number one reticular
activating system it's the science
number two is to trust your intuition
more one of the things that really
helped me back early on in my career was
I
judge myself too harshly for the ideas
that I came up with and as soon as they
came up with an idea I was like oh you
can't do that or I had to have the
perfect Plan before I would ever take
any kind of action on it and you know
just later realize that
you can never plan all the way out
there's no way you know if you wait till
you have the perfect plan by the time
you start actually executing the plan is
is dead it's over
um and so you have to trust in your
ideas and so the thing that really
helped me is
I believe the great ideas flow through
me believe the great ideas flow through
you this is how you shortcut them your
brain that's designed to keep you safe
that's how you shortcut the brain out of
the equation
you came up with an idea as long as it's
in you're in a positive state of mind
you're trying to serve right it's not I
want to I want to go you're you're in a
jealous Rage or you're angry don't trust
your ideas then but when when you're
positive and optimistic and bold and
courageous and an idea comes to you
trust that that's the right idea for you
just trust it it's to write it and then
go do something about it where normally
what we do is we overthink and we over
plan we over prepare and then we lose
the momentum and then the next day and
the next week or the next month it's
gone it's over it's like oh I can't do
that no that was actually a great idea
for you and it's happened enough to me
uh where those things have worked out
where I come up with an idea
and it doesn't make any sense
logically
but I just decide to listen to it and do
something on it and it leads to
something amazing
the amount of times it has happened
is
pretty overwhelming
and so when you have enough repetition
for me I had to see it you know I had to
see it enough times come up because I
wouldn't just believe it on faith I had
to see it happen enough times and you
could test it yourself what ideas in
your head what big idea that you want to
do even a small idea what's what's
flowing through your head when you're in
a positive State you know put on a happy
song move around a little bit and then
notice your thoughts and where it's
going and what you want to create or who
you want to reach out to what you want
to do like what what thought comes to
mind after you're moving around and
having some positive energy that's
probably the right thing for you and
just test it out by doing something
about it and maybe that's a business
idea maybe that's an email you need to
send maybe that's a friend you need to
reach out to maybe that's an act of
kindness that you need to do whatever
the thing is that pops into your mind
trust those ideas and and you could be a
scientist like I'm I like data and I
like science and I like just I like
proving things
maybe I'm a skeptic I don't know but in
running those experiments I I proved to
myself that yeah great ideas do flow
through me
and so the next time I have a great idea
I'm gonna go and take action on it
so number one reticular activating
system
it's already in your environment you're
just ignoring it but if you put
attention towards you start seeing it
like you notice a new car uh when you
buy your new car you see that car
everywhere and then number two is trust
a good ideas flow through you
number three is the one that I'm working
on that I'm I'm having the hardest time
with and I I believe it and I'm trying
to I'm in the process of getting better
at it is
when you're thinking about creating
something to talk to yourself in the
present moment
and this is something that a lot of the
manifestation a lot of Attraction people
talk about but also
people like Grant Cardone talk about it
that is it's not just
the people who would associate with it
but other people have had a lot of
success where you're talking about
whatever thing is that you want that
it's that it's already happened that
it's not going to happen in the future
but that it's already happened you know
if your goal is to speak on stage then
you're visualizing and you're telling
yourself I I am I am on stage I am
speaking to
I am speaking to a million people or
that's that's a giant Stadium
I am speaking uh 70 000 people you know
I am I am the author of a best-selling
book uh I am like whatever your goal is
and what I think the point of that is is
yes one to see yourself accomplishing
big things uh two to not have a be so
far away that it lets you off the hook
for taking action but I think most
importantly is for you to feel what it
feels like to be that and the more you
feel like it feels like to be that the
more it actually becomes true if your
goal is to speak on stage in front of 5
000 people
and you actually
feel like you're doing it you can
visualize yourself being on stage and
doing it
the goal I think I'm still working
through this so one and two I've got
down three is my progress and my journey
so sharing with you
if you feel like you're doing it
if you are on stage and there's 5 000
people clapping for you and cheering you
you just gave the best speech you know
of your life so far
and you feel what it feels like to walk
off that stage and
what a gift that you gave people
that the more comfortable you get with
that feeling
the more it's going to be you and the
more that's going to show up does that
make sense so whatever it is that you
are trying to accomplish
whoever it is that you're trying to be
whatever your big goals are
that you imagine yourself already having
done it
and this is probably not something that
I would tell other people you know like
oh yeah yeah I'm a I'm a you know I'm a
speaker in front of 70 000 people
because because I haven't spoken at a
stadium that big but
to yourself at least
to say it to see it to feel it to do it
if you're trying to heal yourself like
okay I am I am healthy
but look I've got I've got a belly here
I've got a you know whatever I'm I'm I
am healthy I am healthy and and
visualizing yourself being healthy
because you want the feeling of what it
feels like to be healthy and the more
you feel like you are healthy and you
capture that feeling the more frequently
you're in there the more likely it's
going to show up
so that's probably not the most
articulate way to share it and I'm still
working my way through it as well so as
I keep getting better and keep learning
I'll keep sharing with you but
I used to think like manifestation law
of attraction was way out there stuff
that that I judged and that I didn't
understand and that didn't make any
sense like just go off and take action
guys and
with time and experience and exposure
and practice
um using the reticular activating system
to notice things around me by trusting
that great ideas flow through me and
following through and building momentum
and by talking to myself in the present
moment as if I am that person that I
want to become so I can capture that
feeling and know what it feels like to
be that person
I've shifted and seen some pretty
amazing results in my life in business
and I hope it can work for you too you
have to really begin to
mentally rehearse like so you ask
yourself at the end of your day I do
this every day how'd I do how'd I do
today bro how'd you do just do good
where'd you fall from grace what what
what was it
that caused you to go unconscious
for the rest of the day like what was
that moment now if you're a student of
life
you'll begin to contemplate well it was
that person that said that thing then I
reacted or this I got this email or
things didn't go my way and I started
feeling angry or frustrated or fearful
the next time that happens
how could I involve my experience now
you may have to search for some answers
of the best model to build or you may
actually have a long contemplation and
start to go God the next time that
happens I think I'm gonna do this or I'm
going to do that or I'm going to plan my
behaviors
and the act of closing your eyes
and rehearsing what you're going to do
begins to install the neurological
Hardware in your brain to looks like you
already did it now the brain is no
longer a record of the past now it's a
map to the Future and if you keep
installing that Hardware the hardware
will become a software program which
means you'll just start acting like a
happy person why there's no magic there
you install the circuitry so
that's more important than the news
right it's more important than answering
any email or any text it's more
important than talking about your past
or some dinner
if you can begin to just
think about how you're going to do it
differently that's the building process
neurologically already so now you have
to get conscious in order to do that and
it takes some time it means you got to
shut your cell phone off you got to
close your door you got to take a break
from everything out there and begin to
practice and so by experience then
you start noticing oh here it comes here
comes the frustration here comes the
fear
and now we've given people the tools to
be able to self-regulate to create brain
and heart coherence and so you see
people say excuse me one minute I'm just
gonna need a minute
is take some breaths they get back in
they connect to the energy of their
future this is incidental compared to
where they're going so they don't fall
from grace they don't allow their energy
to drop and so yeah in the beginning it
takes a lot because it takes a lot of
energy and awareness to stay conscious
and not go unconscious but if you're
persistent and you're determined then
you're sincere
you begin to figure it out you begin to
say I am not going to give my power away
to that person or that circumstance when
I can use it to heal or to create a new
future and so people then won't excuse
themselves and say on a hard day
yesterday at a fight with my co-worker
or my ex or and I don't feel like doing
the work well that's the time they get
back on the horse yeah because because
it's the it's all of those times that we
self-correct those are the most valuable
moments thus people who've had
profoundly transcendental experiences
where they we say got lit up they
connected and their brain goes into very
very high coherent States and super
gamma patterns that are way outside of
normal and they have a transcendental
downloader connection that's mystical
they look back at their entire life
they don't want to change one thing in
their past because it got them to that
moment that's the moment the past no
longer exists now by the same means they
look back at their past and they see all
those tough moments where they overcame
themselves and they fall in love with
that person they don't look at the good
meditations or the things that went well
they look they know that it was those
moments that got them to this moment and
I I think then that's when they begin to
understand that that all of the hard
work
all the effort in who we become makes no
one can take that away from us so then
once we arrive at that level and we
experience whatever the dream is or
whatever we create the next thing is do
it until you fully enjoy it and then
when it gets boring or predictable let's
go again let's do something else I'm in
this three-year journey of trying to
conceive and really for a year and a
half almost two years I was like in the
low of it really feeling like okay I'm
not good enough my body isn't working
how can I make this happen how can I
make this happen right really pushing
and controlling and trying to eat things
and track my ovulation and all that crap
and that about the fall of 2017 I
started to get into more of a
surrendered State and I started
practicing the methods that I teach in
the book of just really trusting that
there was a higher guidance that I
believed in for my whole life and
relying on that and that's when things
started to get really wild and
synchronistic and so around the fall of
2017 I was driving in the countryside
where I live most of the time and this
is where I do the majority of my
manifesting is just driving in the car
looking at the foliage listening to my
Mantra music and I feel so awesome when
I'm in that position and I'm just so
grateful in the moment and I'm driving
and I'm driving I'm like I feel so
awesome and so grateful that I live in
this country town and I have all these
friends and I don't have any cell
service right now and I'm so psyched
about that and no one's bothering me and
I feel good and then all of a sudden I
felt the presence of a baby in the back
seat and I was like wow like deeply
moved tears started to roll down my face
I felt so moved and at that point I
heard my intuition say to me
the baby's coming in March
and I was like and it was so loud like
you know when you hear the voice of your
inspiration you're like that's it okay I
believe and so I started saying to
myself over and over like oh my God
March you know I have to conceive at
this time for the baby to come and watch
I saw myself getting a little into it
like too into it and hooked into it so I
said okay listen you know what Universe
I'm gonna give this over and if my baby
is indeed coming in March Show Me A Sign
show me lilies to let me know that the
baby's coming in March and a week later
I got in a letter in the mail from a
reader and it had this Angel Card in it
and on the back of it was this picture
of Archangel Gabriel and Archangel
Gabriel is typically depicted holding
lilies so I was like yo this is dope and
on the back he wrote
I thought that you needed this and I was
like thank you good so here I am March
March is coming March is happening and
early March rolled around and I wasn't
pregnant so I was like what the hell and
Not only was I devastated once again
another month has gone by I'm not
pregnant but this time I was like I
thought the universe had my back like I
was getting signs like what what's the
uh what's up so I walked into my
husband's office and I was just
hysterically crying so upset so defeated
and it's some my phone was like on the
desk like right here
and all of a sudden my phone started
playing a song
and the song was just repeating
repeating it's like go like you know
when your phone malfunctions you're like
I'm just going to turn that off I was
like okay I'm just gonna turn that out
and then I look at the phone and I start
listening to the lyrics and the lyrics
are way go Lily Way go Lily and the guy
keeps repeating way go Lily and then I
look even further and I look at the name
of the song as way go Lily and he keeps
repeating Lily and I look even further
and the album title is I see the sign
and where was this playing where what
area have you found this was just my
phone just turned on oh well no that's
good you know it's Spirit working
through the technology and so my phone
just turned on it was an album that I'd
never heard I'd never heard the song
before it wasn't in my Spotify and it
just began playing now get this
so I get I I April rolls around and I'm
pregnant
but then I did the math and I was like
when did I conceive
I conceived the last day of March um
so that synchronicity you know you hear
March you find your signs you feel super
guided that synchronicity is available
to all of us but it's what it had we
have to get out of that push or
mentality and out of that controlling
Behavior to allow the presence of spirit
to work through us and guide us and or
the universe or whatever use whatever
you call it to be the presence of of of
Direction inspiration when I was small
um I was also really undersized so it's
probably one of the reasons I lift
weights I was always every baseball
picture on the kid holding a sign in the
front right so I was small and skinny uh
they used to tease me Eddie's spaghetti
you know and I'd get bullied at school
and I never retaliated so I had that
mixed with shyness mixed with chaos in
my home which many people can relate to
and I gotta tell you that the shift for
me Sports was good for me because it
gave me an out that I finally found
something that I was pretty good at
I think the biggest shift in our lives
the things that makes us the happiest is
that when somebody helps us identify our
natural giftedness
and when I was a little boy I got a
little bit older they pointed out my
speed
so it wasn't my lack of size I was fast
I was the fast kid right I always wanted
to be fast kid and I got confidence in
baseball doing that when I got into
business I said you know you're intense
when someone points out a gift about you
that you also kind of intuitively know
to be true
they're linked to them you're intense
you're passionate you won't get out work
you're Relentless I want I am those
things and when someone linked those
gifts to me winning now I believed I
could win that's the other way to change
identity is when someone can link your
giftedness to the victory you'll believe
it not like you're great that's General
that's [ __ ] right but it's something
you know specifically like for you right
now you wouldn't brag about them there's
a few things you know you know what I am
good at these things right I've always
been good at these things it's natural
for me and when someone links back to
you winning like for you for example
you're an unbelievable interviewer you
have this General you you don't need to
be the smartest person in the room
because you probably are most of the
time and so there's a confidence no
there's a confidence that allows you to
be present when you interview me and
just listen that's different than anyone
who's interviewed me before and so
that's a natural giftedness for you
which is why there's a part of you that
kind of knows I am pretty you wouldn't
say it but I am pretty good at this this
is a good program and so the way we
change your identity the way I changed
mine was by getting in touch with what
some of my natural gifts were and and
using them in my career using them in my
life that shifted the weight right off
of me because the weight was I suck I'm
shy I'm small I have a screwed up family
that's the weight right the lifting off
of the weight is these are some gifts
God gave me or the universe gave me or
that at least I know I have and I can
spend my life using these gifts now I've
got hope now my identity is changing now
my life takes a different direction so
if you take
any event that's occurred in the past if
you just merely think of that event
that's occurred in the past chances are
you're firing off the neural network of
that pattern right so you can take
um uh the idea of eating your favorite
dessert what do you think is happening
in your brain when you pretend you're
eating that favorite dessert of yours
and your mouth starts to water and you
start to feel oh that's such a great
dessert that's neurons in your brain
firing in the neurochemistry that is
associated with that memory firing now
let's say
that you have a disempowering pattern of
being embarrassed or ashamed or
ridiculed but instead of just thinking
about the pattern oh I don't like it as
soon as you think about the pattern and
it has a I'm going to say a
disempowering or negative emotion
chances are that means that the stress
Center in the brain has been activated
that means that your heartbeat's going
to go up that means that your sweat
glands are going to be activated that
means you're going to breathe a little
bit less uh uh deeply I mean more
shallowly
and that is the fear or stress response
now what if instead of allowing that to
continue you just stopped
and you had this intention
I'm going to dissolve the effectiveness
or the strength of this pattern how do
you do that well first and foremost you
stop you sit and you start with inner
size number one that actually I guide
you through in the book
all right and enter size number one
is called take six calm the circuits so
you want to move from your stress and
react system
to your relax and response system you
have
parasympathetic and sympathetic nervous
systems okay that are triggered within
the body so what happens when you sit
quietly and you take six deep breaths in
through your nose
and out through your mouth like you're
blowing out through a straw when you do
it six times in 10 second rhythmic
breaths
and you focus on the air that you're
blowing out through your mouth like
you're blowing out through a straw that
simple inner size
is inner size number one take six calm
the circuits it actually
deactivates the stress fear
embarrassment shame guilt circuit
and in a quiet relaxed state
that same memory does not have the same
power
but if you don't do it in that state you
do it in a in a tense stressful State
you're actually reinforcing that pattern
versus thinking about bringing up that
old memory and doing this repetitively
10 times 20 times 30 times 40 times
until the neurons really don't fire that
strength at that strength level I don't
think people really realize we construct
Our Lives we build them from nothing we
decide what our goals are we decide in
what way to move we decide who we're
going to become and what we're going to
get but it's a decision it's a process
it isn't something that somebody hands
to you
and so if you find that your life is a
misery understand that your life is an
exact reflection of your choices and if
you want a different life you need only
make a different choice
but I know right now many of you are
thinking but I don't know what way to go
I don't know what choice to make I don't
know what it is that I want to do and as
Roy Maurice Keane said I don't believe
skill was or ever will be the result of
coaches it is a result of A Love Affair
between the child and the ball
so ask yourself
what's that thing you love and don't
judge yourself if it was something that
you loved as a child that people are
telling you you couldn't possibly make
money and it's that part of the equation
that I want to break for people I want
you to understand stop asking yourself
what you can make a lot of money at and
start asking yourself what would you
enjoy what is that life that you don't
need to escape from what is the life
that is your love what is the thing that
as a kid you did whether people wanted
you to or not what is the thing you
would sneak out at night to do because
you weren't going to be stopped from
doing it everybody has something like
that in their life some spark of
Interest maybe long dormant maybe that
they've pushed aside because they think
it's stupid
I'm bad at it
even though they love it that sting of
the failure has convinced them to stop
pursuing him
but at the end of the day the only thing
that matters is what gives you that
energy at the end of the day the thing
that matters is what fills you with joy
at the end of the day the only thing
that matters it's not success and sure
this hell isn't money
time you feel about yourself when you're
by yourself it's the things that give
you energy
think about yourself it's how you react
to the hard things it's whether or not
you push through
and when you push through when you
persevere when you go down the process
of taking the time to structure your
life to build it into something that you
want it to be to build it into something
that you're proud of to become the
person that's capable of the things you
want to do that can first fall in love
with something and Do It For the Love of
it and not worry about what other people
think if you hate your life I guarantee
you the thing is that you were trapped
by what other people think you don't
want to give it up because somebody will
think you're a failure you don't want to
give it up because it's a paycheck you
don't want to give it up because as
you're scared
you're scared you don't know what you'll
do next
but imagine a world for a second where
all you thought about was what do you
love what do you enjoy in that moment it
doesn't matter if it changes from day to
day just what do you love what fills you
with joy what gives you that energy at
the end of the day the only thing that
we all have is right now this moment
it's what you're experiencing
loving what you do how you spend your
time
point of all of it the point of life is
that in each transient moment that
passes by doing something that fills you
with joy
nobody can give you that
you've got to build that life so go out
figure out what it is that you want to
do and Brick by Brick have the courage
to build that life I think we're all
faced with great opportunities
brilliantly disguised as impossible
situations and in order like for me
personally and I and after looking
through your book and reading a good
portion of it I mean for me there's
there's no school of ancient wisdom that
you need to go to be initiated your life
is your initiation if you're paying
attention so we meet challenges in our
life from a certain level of mind right
a certain level of Consciousness or
unconsciousness and even Einstein said
we have to go to a greater level of
consciousness
uh then the Consciousness that's created
the problem well what is consciousness
Consciousness is awareness and awareness
means possibilities that you haven't
thought of before so we could we
confront problems or challenges in our
life and as a side note I was having
breakfast with a researcher just last
week who's studying what happens when we
perceive and condition in our
environment as a problem how it weakens
the organism they're measuring this and
when a person sees it as a challenge how
they draw energy they raise the energy
of their body back into order
so if we said I want to be
wealthy or I want to be healthy
well what what you want to be that
because you're not it
so the initiation of going from not it
here to it here you're going to have to
climb some steps and there's going to be
some blind spots so you try it out and
it doesn't work
well that's because there's a part of
you that's still in a habit there's part
of you that's still unconscious okay so
what is it about myself and that
circumstance
that I am feeling about that
circumstance and that feeling is causing
me to think about it so you say oh it's
impossible they'll never change I'll
hire a hit man I'll hire the mafia I'll
hire an attorney I'll hit my friend's
friend to talk to him and nothing
changes right well
you're not you're not separate from that
experience you're involved in it and how
you think and how you feel broadcasts
energy into the field so your energy is
the same every day and as long as your
energy is the same nothing's going to
change in your life either and nobody
changes until they change their energy
so then
what piece of knowledge what piece of
information what would love do what
would greatness look like okay I don't
know all right well certainly somebody
in history has faced this problem
don't get on Facebook and say does
anybody have any answers don't get go
look it up and study and breed and learn
you'll own it and you'll say wow that
person that was wealthy
they failed 500 times well hell I had
the wrong view of wealth okay then
failure is not a thing I gotta overcome
failure well yep just climb the step
yeah okay I'm reacting to that
circumstance with the same emotion that
emotion is firing the same thoughts I'm
broadcasting the same energy into the
field if I were facing that circumstance
and situation again with that person
that circumstance what do I learn from
that circumstance how could I do it
differently the next time
find out a solution and rehearse it
install the circuitry so when you get in
the circumstance you're not going to
respond in an automatic habituation yeah
now you're at a greater level of
Consciousness now you're looking at
possibilities that you weren't looking
at before because you're unconscious now
that process of trial and error is so
important in the spiritual path
how many times
do we have to forget before we remember
and then we remember and we forget again
and it takes constantly remembering
until we stop forgetting and when we get
to that point now we're conscious now
there's wisdom and wisdom is the memory
of the experience without the emotional
charge now you're ready for the new
adventure so then
people draw conclusions and say oh it's
that person that ripped me off as that
person that that what now now you don't
create your reality you only create your
reality when things are good no well
somehow you got to Tango through this
somehow your objectivity in not reacting
emotionally
is going to change the energy of how you
address this situation when the fear
signal has kicked in
all right it's releasing the
neurochemicals like I said epinephrine
cortisol norepinephrine which is
adrenaline
um and some of it's good too much of it
will cause you to fight to freeze to
flee run away or defaint those are the
four okay possible outcomes for the
stress response or fear response system
when it kicks in so when that switch is
turned on think of it as a light switch
that just turned on in your brain and
then there's a Cascade okay of
neurochemicals that causes a feeling if
you focus on the feeling then you're
going to think about what you feel then
you're going to feel what you think
about you create this self-fulfilling
Doom Loop of neurochemicals being rushed
in your body and if you do that every
day every week every month over and over
again you've now just set up a doom Loop
habit where that fear is going to drive
your thoughts and emotions and behaviors
or lack thereof but what I want you to
do is recognize the fear
calmly and you do this as soon as you
recognize the fear that you can bring up
on your own you do the first inner size
okay inner size exercise for your
physical body and your organs inner size
for your neural muscles all right so
when you feel fear be in observation of
it like the light comes on in the dash
of your car and then what you do is you
take six deep breaths but here's how you
do it
in through your nose out through your
mouth like you're blowing out of a straw
so it goes like this six breaths 10
seconds each ready
deep rhythmic breaths in up in the lungs
expand the diaphragm so you get the
diaphragm and the lungs expanding
and you breathe out like you're
breathing through a straw so you focus
the energy
out through the mouth it causes your
brain to actually get oxygenated and
guess why you want that well when we're
in a state of fear we activate Okay the
vagus nerve which constricts your blood
flow it slows down your heartbeat it
causes shallow breathing so as soon as
you alternate from that fear and stress
response system to the calm
I'm sorry from the from the stress and
react system to the calm and response
system your brain shuts off the fear
circuit and activates the left
prefrontal cortex exam where you can
think because blood flows back there
again so if fear is holding you back
there's nothing wrong with fear but
there just be maybe
um a lack of skill of knowing when or
what to do does this make sense so far
does this make sense so far so when you
take those six deep rhythmic breaths
that is what deactivates that stress
response system in the brain and
activates the relax and respond you want
to be in a responsive State as much as
possible versus a reactive state
[Music]
as you made it this far in a video I
want to celebrate you most people start
and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for even
more powerful manifestation techniques
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there I think the Law
of Attraction and manifesting are the
same thing so Law of Attraction for
everybody who has not read the secret is
simply your thoughts become things and
it's true we've talked all about how
when you have a negative self-talk it
tends to draw
[Music]